so this is probably my favorite camera
that I own it's my Panasonic vhs-c palm
Corder hopefully that was in focus I
have used it a few times to shoot some
of my own videos but easily the person
who's used it the most is my gran and
recently I took on the pretty laborious
task of trying to digitize all of her
old home video
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
this is written behind the camera
that's it that's all hope you enjoyed it
yeah you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool
okie dokie here's last week's video in
case you missed that one and if you
would like to see more of tiny little me
here is the spider Charlie video in full
it's quite a treat I promise you even if
you hate children I think you'll like
this one and they're so good bye